I posted for two months consistently
like every single day it happened
because I had a friend who was sleeping
on my couch he had just moved to LA he
started doing Tick Tock and like posting
a lot he's a beat boxer and he blew up
in like six months he gained 50 million
followers oh my God became a
multi-millionaire I saw and he still
slept on your couch no because it was it
that same day he was still there these
are my Louis Vuitton sheets on the couch
she's really talented but like he was so
consistent with it that changed his life
covet happened and I was like okay I
need to make money if I started pushing
on Tick Tock I was consistent for about
two months wasn't getting any traction
and just one day a video blew up and it
was just like was it this one the
freaking yeah the flip one yeah so easy
anyway that's something that she could
have done any day for years yeah like
Tick Tock is always like the dumbest
[ __ ] you wouldn't expect to love that
blows up wow thanks okay
I mean the most uncreated thing you've
ever seen
bottom of the barrel yeah what you're
saying yeah